j'ai peine à club il a donné un second
souffle à la ventriloquie avec sa
marionnette jean-marc avant lui les
ventriloques ont connu leur heure de
gloire grâce à la télévision et ce dès
les premières éditions de variétés parmi
les grandes voix du métier voici david
michel et sa marionnette nestor composé
de 900 pièces ici en 1981 nous sommes là
pour distraire nos amis non alors on
reste ici
david michel et les stores sont des
stars à l'époque triste preuve de leur
notoriété
en 1980 le ventriloque raconte comment
sa marionnette a été kidnappé avec
demande de rançon la télévision la radio
tout le monde en a parlé et pendant peu
près huit jeux en dérange mes
kidnappeurs me rançonner au téléphone
plus encore que nestor le chouchou
ultime du public c'est lui ta taille est
manipulé par michel dejeneffe ils ont su
sans cesse renouveler l'exercice en 1982
dans l'émission champs elysées l'homme
apprend à sa marionnette à devenir à son
tour ventriloque tu lui mets la main
dans la tête la ctq
c'est le seul moyen ça y est je trouve
pas les trous dépêchera de 20 km 1 allez
construire le petit écran fait une place
aux ventriloque pendant une quinzaine
d'années leurs sketches dure entre 2 et
10 minutes alors il faut rivaliser de
créativité comme marque mettra alors en
1983 lorsque j'appuie une fois sur votre
main ou d'ouvriers fois la bouche
ok c'est 4 marionnettes du jour sont
humaines
[Musique]
1975 1990 c'était l'âge d'or des
ventriloques après ça certains comme
michel dejeneffe et marc métral ont
continué à animer leurs marionnettes
occasionnellement comme un désamour pour
l'art de la ventriloquie jusqu'à ce
qu'il revienne en force ces dernières
années avec un humour plus décapant
[Musique]